- Hello.
- [Narrator] Normally
when you think of words,
they fit into a language.
- Bonjour.
- [Narrator] But there's
a relatively new class
of words that don't quite follow the rules
and it's called wasei-eigo.
John Kelly is a language writer.
- [John] I spend a lot of my time
writing about word origins.
- [Narrator] He's a linguistics
expert and he knows just
about everything about the
phenomenon called wasei-eigo.
- [John] Wasei-eigo literally
means Japan-made English.
It is a language process
that takes foreign words,
usually English words
and transmogrifies them
into something wholly new and
novel for Japanese purposes.
We see this with a word like karaoke.
Everybody knows and
everybody loves karaoke,
but it joins the Japanese
kara, which means empty
and oke, which is a Japanese
rendering of orchestra.
So a karaoke is an empty orchestra.
- [Narrator] The most popular
example is the word Pokémon.
- [John] The creator of Pokémon took
two English words, pocket and monster.
He smashed them together and got Pokémon.
- [Narrator] Or take cosplay,
a word that describes
people dressing up as
fictional characters.
- [John] Cosplay joins costume and play.
- [Narrator] And there's anime.
- [John] Anime is a
fairly straight forward
rendering of the English animation.
Wasei-eigo is important
because language is always
changing and reinventing itself.
- [Narrator] What new words
will pop up in the future?
Only time will tell.